we begin at this hour with a piece of
delicious news very very delicious so
Cheng Chi ger he's the founder of a
group called The Young Turks it's a show
that's been promoted by YouTube they
funded it shanks channel has been very
popular for a long time if you ever want
to see a video of me debating Chiang Kai
debated him politican maybe two years
ago three years ago anyway
shank is a far left dude he's running
for Congress in the old seat that Katy
Hill occupied the the woman who just had
to step down for apparently engaging in
a corrupt menage a trois with one of her
staffers well now he's running for the
Democratic nomination for that seat he
endorsed Bernie then Bernie endorsed him
back then it turned out that Jenkins had
a bunch of stuff that people found
offensive so Bernie promptly threw chanc
overboard well Jenkins made his entire
career off of being a wildly progressive
voice wildly progressive spending his
time on the evils of money and politics
and the joys of unionization
unfortunately for Chang he operates a
business and that led to this delicious
little scenario today according to The
Huffington Post top leadership at the
progressive News Network The Young Turks
held an all staff meeting at its office
in Culver City California on February
12th
the regularly scheduled gathering was
supposed to deal with personnel matters
but instead the focus turned to the
staffs nascent union campaign which had
just gone public earlier that day a
Twitter handle claiming to represent
Young Turks employees had announced on
the social media platform that their
intention to form a union in the staff
meeting the network's co-founder an
influential host shang-chi gur urged
employees not to do so arguing that a
union does not belong at a small
independent outlet like The Young Turks
according to two workers who were
present he said if there had been a
union at the network it would not have
grown the way it has oh that's delicious
that's that's some solid stuff just
straight into my veins man straight into
the veins I'm gonna mainline this stuff
the beauty I'm a person like Chang who
spends his entire career basically
railing against employers for not being
kind enough to employees he's a Bernie
Sanders guy and Bernie spends his entire
life unions have to take over the
corporation's have fun corporations have
to be represented by the workers
otherwise just not it's not true it's
corrupt
otherwise it's evil it's exploitation
and here's chanc going yeah well here's
the thing now here's the thing if we
unionize we're gonna bankrupt it's like
Oh welcome welcome to the Republican
Party chanc Eiger his talk at times
emotional the staffer said with Eiger
throwing his papers to the ground at one
point in chess I think he seemed to
contradict the progressive worker first
ethos that the Young Turks broadcast was
millions of lefty followers Jack Gerrard
acting as the company's chief operating
officer his Eiger runs for Congress told
the staff they were not discouraging
unionization but the message from Eiger
was clear and to at least some of the
staffers discouraging we generally feel
disappointed but unshaken said one
staffer who spoke on the condition of
anonymity for fear of retaliation we
feel it's the right thing to do because
of what the Young Turks values in an
interview with Huffington Post Eiger
said he's a strong supporter of unions
especially at large corporations that
aren't sharing profits with their
workers but he says he worries a
unionized workforce would bring new
legal and bureaucratic cost that the
Young Turks can't sustain by the way the
Young Turks very successful like
millions and millions and millions of
dollars in revenue every year the
network has a growing subscription-based
and has raised enormous venture capital
money but many of the same headwinds as
other online media dealing with the
collapse of ad revenue the reality is
were in a precarious position positions
had agar we're in a digital media
landscape where almost no one makes
money or is sustainable he added for a
smaller digital media company those are
absolutely real considerations it
doesn't mean you shouldn't have a union
everyone should know the full context if
folks say they don't believe we're in a
precarious position okay and that's
their decision to make so he's saying I
the employer I'm not out to screw my
employees I'm here to run a successful
business and that means you can't
unionize against me because that's gonna
lead to additional cost and then they
may have to fire some people but
everybody else should unionize and if
you don't unionize it's because you're
corrupt and evil Shang tiger Uyghur said
he was caught off guard by the Union
effort that appeared on Twitter the day
of the meeting and it was so early in
the process he wasn't sure if it was
real or if he was being Punk'd he
acknowledged that he threw papers in the
meeting that he reprimanded an employee
whom he believed to be smiling according
to staffers Eiger said it would be funny
later and it an ominous statement they
found unsettling he told Huffington Post
it wasn't meant to be a threat he said
the person seems smiling seems to be
openly mocking the idea that the company
might not survive after 18 years
and we put all this blood sweat and
tears into it I don't find the idea of
us going down funny welcome to being an
employer Chiang Kai gur welcome to the
business world Chiang Kai gur welcome to
capitalism Chiang Kai gir we're trying
to run a successful business and it
turns out that bullcrap like unionizing
employees who demand things that are not
sustainable will wreck your business but
he's supporting Bernie wants to forcibly
unionize half the American workforce
it's unbelievable and wonderful the
campaign at TYT comes with another
wrinkle a Gers attempt to fill the
congressional seat vacated by former
representative katie hill agar is
running to the left in the Democratic
primary the front-runner Kristy Smith a
California Assemblywoman has the backing
of the party establishment in many labor
unions as the union spat became more
public Eiger suggested on twitter that
the union campaign was politically
motivated by the international alliance
of theatrical stage employees the union
trying to organize TYT they've already
endorsed Smith in the race but staffers
say no no we've been trying to unionize
for two years unbelievable it's just
spectacular he says at the end of the
day my opinion on it is irrelevant it's
the employees who get to decide and who
should decide so he's saying they should
decide but also I'm gonna tell them that
if they decide and we go under then it's
their fault
just spectacular just spectacular and
well-earned it's always fun when
capitalism in reality come back to bite
socialists directly on their posterior
I hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did go ahead and
hit the subscribe button so you stay up
to date on all of our future content